cuando los rusos tomaron gerson después
de la invasión del 24 de febrero la vida
de miles y miles de niños y adolescentes
cambió no solamente por las nuevas
circunstancias sino también en la manera
que accedían a la educación El currículo
cambió por completo y lo que intentaron
imponer fue el sistema educativo ruso
decidimos que comenzaríamos las clases
más tarde así los niños venían al
colegio a las 8 donde había
colaboradores que les enseñaban bajo el
sistema Ruso y a las 11 cuando iban a
casa continuábamos nuestra educación
ucraniana online de acuerdo con el
programa ruso de acuerdo con los libros
rusos formaban a nuestros niños
ucranianos para que atendieran a las
clases porque amenazaban con que si no
lo hacían se los quitarían a los padres
durante estos meses las profesores han
buscado las opciones para seguir
educando a la mayoría de los niños a
través de internet El Gran reto Es que
muchos de ellos no están en gerson ni
siquiera en Ucrania sino por fuera del
país
[Música]
el internet era muy malo aunque a veces
funcionaba algunas veces se quedaba
congelado y las lecciones tenían que
parar
[Música]
todavía no sabemos qué va a pasar no
sabemos si nos quedamos mi prima nos
llamó hoy para contarnos que en el
sector donde vive están atacando cayó un
misil cerca de su casa y Perdieron su
carros
la educación online tiene grandes retos
para los jóvenes de ejercer
especialmente porque no hay electricidad
detrás de mí hay uno de esos ejemplos
maravillosos una joven que viene aquí a
cargar su celular y aprovecha que hay
buen internet para poder seguir sus
estudios
durante la ocupación la vida No fue
fácil eso seguro teníamos que esconder
los teléfonos todos los símbolos
ucranianos todo por el simple hecho de
ser ucranianos pero ahora es más fácil
perdón
[Música]